so
hello everyone and welcome to another
gamespot play for all
charity stream today it's time
for the contenders to become pros
commanders we're not pretenders we are
contenders that's the truth
that's right uh so i'll
i'll introduce everyone before i kind of
giving the rundown of what we're doing
here today uh i'm lucy you might
know me i don't want to do a doctor nick
i work at gamespot uh joining me today
we've got andy cortez hello everybody
i'm
right now i'm doing all the social stuff
i'm posting to instagram
and doing all that stuff bring eyes to
the to this champion squad that's about
to dominate
the landscape and the servers right now
you all are in the uk
we're in america it's a worldwide
domination of servers in overwatch right
now that's every country
[Laughter]
my overwatch game has just like crashed
as well so great starting
hell yeah hell yeah blaine gibson
you guys super happy to be here really
really down to do some uh some heels
and that's about it yep no kills
no kills just heels uh
james williams hella i'm just listen
you guys know how much this squad means
to me all right this squad is my beating
heart
inside my chest it's the most fun crew
i've ever had playing this game
that i played for a very long time with
a lot of people love this crew and i
can't wait to get some w's today
hell yeah and joel reuben uh
you're all honored to have me here i
understand um
so you're welcome for being here uh
you know kids let me talk to you about
the uh
stain clearing properties of the baby
detergent
oh we're trying to get a sponsorship out
of their charities like
if we're all trying to get sponsorship
i'm just going to have this uh sip of
this refreshing diet coke
uh and the difference i have my mountain
dew rise thank you
uh and that disembodied voice you may
hear you won't see his face but you'll
hear his voice and you'll be watching
his overwatch league worthy gameplay
is to hussein i'm impressed that joel
went for the cleaner instead of the
lacroix lacroix feels like
it would be a much safer bet for a
sponsorship land
but more money proctor and gamble or
some company that's based in the upper
midwest
that's fair point that's a very fair
plan it's a very good point
this is this is why i don't get
sponsored and he does
not
uh so we as a crew play overwatch
together um
well we used to play semi regularly and
then uh
tomorrow and i decided to bugger off and
go back to the united kingdom
turns out it's difficult to coordinate
over very very different time zones
however
we've come together today in the name of
charity we are raising money for
ablegamers we are so so close
to 10k so if you have a few dollars to
spare
to go towards an incredible charity
seriously look up what amor gamers does
they do amazing work
uh helping people with disabilities
combat social isolation
they uh engineer and give out
specialized hardware
uh for people with disabilities so that
they can play um as well as a whole
bunch of other stuff so we are raising
money to go to them we are so close to
10k it would be incredible if we could
hit it on this stream
this crew has come together for one
night only
to help us get there and hopefully also
win some games
let's play we just we make one ask
of our of the people watching a dime
every time we catch w donate a dime
we'll blow this blow this goal out of
the water
but if just in case you should also
donate anyway
how about you each each win is a dime
each quarter
is or each losses in quarter dollar yeah
wait but in uk terms
pins
[Music]
[Music]
about how about everyone donates ten
dollars every time we play a game
yeah that's great i love that how about
that one that smells good
i'll do that um i want it to be known
that i
am playing on controller because only
because it's only because
a i'm going to be playing probably a lot
of moira don't need to aim
uh but also i'm on a dining table and i
just don't have
i don't have the facilities for it big
man um don't think you've got the
facilities for that big man
i love how close your dining table is to
a diver's helmet
look okay i have a diverse helmet i've
got like a mass effect helmet i have a
halo helmet i have helmets for every
potential scenario i also have like
a an actual like old medieval helmet too
so you know
if anything anything goes down i'm here
i'm ready to bug out i'm also
imagining you have a full english
breakfast with all the beans
right in front of you just to the side
of your
apple i'm trying to think do i have
anything quintessentially british next
to me
e do we have tea books we don't
read in america no
how much cleaning solution do you have
next to you
technically technically you've got the
most british thing
in england always around you and that's
universal healthcare
um so you're just you're just swimming
in it
i mean we could basically say that about
any developed nation that is in america
true yeah don't get too cocky
is that the fastest man in the uk andy
cortez it sure is that's me
um as you all know i beat greg in a race
in the uk
and he thinks that he can beat me in
america because for some reason he
thinks the locations matter
what yeah is there more gravity or
something
i i don't know i don't know it's craig
miller who knows you guys are really
pushed up
just so you know there's that thing
happening right now where you can get uh
oh we can get some uh some skins ins and
stuff we just need i think 27 wins
that's all
easy look at that in two hours
especially when um i died immediately
we could do it i i'm sorry yeah
it was it was kind of like you i would i
know but
oh oh right don't go where i came
reckless
watch out for that hanzo
someone in the youtube chat says sounds
like they know they will lose a lot
how dare you okay what are you talking
about
oh that was definitely meant for ryan
but it's fine i got their rhymes i got
their rhymes
they're on fire ffa says there's more
wind
behind us behind the camera which is why
behind here
there's a mccreader someone coming here
thank you i got the ryan
he's actually aiming
all right
[Music]
oh
[Music]
saved them on that one yeah you really
did oh
uh hands up i'll keep trying to switch
to my knife andy
[Laughter]
we are not playing that we are not
playing all right now
captivating cats we are watching tam
screen yeah uh
i apologize for my game zarya play um
you'll see him in the next season of
overwatch league play for san francisco
shock
yep much the chagrin of a lot of
spitfire fans
well they didn't sort the contract out
for you so
it's their own fault oh man
oh no um it's too risky
yeah it's very risky oh
wow
oh no
no no no oh i can only throw the date
oh damn
it's fine
i've got my all ready gonna hold on to
it until we can make something happen
oh no
right above your head is your isolated
thank you oh no uh mccree's next to the
cop
he's saying hello to us guys don't trust
him
don't believe his lies sorry sorry i'll
put my mic closer
gamer sorry oh
all right i'm going to come back in if
you can stall i'll have my heart
no oh that moira what's happened here
oh god it's just gaming so hard right
now
we gotta out game the game oh my god
you're gonna sleep by me
you know we're just warming up guys yeah
first first one warm up that mccree
gonna read some uh read some donations
let's go let's go play the game though
so
let's go victory right there
congratulations on winning that match
thank you very much wow like we did we
did a great hit
and you've got six votes as well a
second to win already look at us that's
two
we're dominating two wins
for who to vote for i know god we're so
coordinated
you know online zero damage
guys
but i'm pretty sure i did too uh
so we got ten dollars in from luca
uh ryan gsr another ten dollars thank
you augie mojo
twenty dollars thank you uh chase
mullins ten dollars
everyone should be able to experience
the wonderful stories video games can
offer
co-signed thank you so much chase
anonymous in there with twenty dollars
uh vaughn w ten dollars with love this
crew
hey remember us when we're in the big
leagues
follow our journey all the way on rank
quickly isn't the big leagues
what oh this is the the
the early big weeks and then there's a
later one early to mid
ish yeah yeah and then gerardo is cool
with five dollars keep on keeping on
y'all i'll be over watching y'all on my
lunch break oh god that was
wait wait oh god that was terrible
don't put yourself down straight yeah
we're fine you know what
it was bad we need another donation yeah
oh wow
the only thing that will i mean we've
got
coordination down but do we have aiming
you know what would help a donation tiny
or elder gun
let's play for all twenty win huh yeah
of watches uh go on peterborough
and uh i'm sorry that i am the person
that's that's why
kaplan left it's not don't
let's see if we can get some hooks i'll
go roadhog lined up let's see if we can
get some hooks
with the vanilla reinhardt skin you know
you gotta go with the originals there's
a reason that that was the default skin
is because it looks so good
it does look good you know yeah i'm
going old school
push up a bit i mean james has got the
stunt master 76 going on
right
wow there's no melting to me here come
the uh
here comes the pain i mean
they are pushing hard right
i'm dead i'm sorry
i have not seen an echo in overwatch
that's her name um yeah
zen's losing slow really that's like the
pro meta
yeah everybody always goes echo don't
blow up my spot andy i'm not pro
no no look we tasted weird when i i'm
down in silver i don't see any
it's weird i don't see anything oh no
i try and go i try and hold for 45
seconds
it's it's like doing a plane second you
just need a minute
or a key goal perhaps yeah yeah
it's a it's just it's the first kpi
echo pi okay performance indicator
all right we can do this
you're a bunch of softies uh where is
james you all right that slice it yet
yeah trying to get this reporter
oh oh good god oh
i gotcha all right nevermind nice
apparently you can't go
i hoped her anyway everyone chat soda
i threw a hook as she was trans sam i've
got yoga thank you
oh
uh andy back
oh nice hook nice
we're playing pushing back pushing back
we got diva over here we've got dave up
top
diva and it looks like i think it's a
metro yeah
oh i'm an idiot i'm gonna go up there
and give him some
brief echo pick up that they've got a
teleport right here
oh they're behind me
yeah they keep tp and putting uh
pictures up top little turrets down
behind us
oh big golf bagel oh god
zin's by himself yes get him getting
getting in
uh there was one right next to andy but
i got it yeah i don't know where they're
bonus
i heard it they're webcams microwaves
yeah oh they've got a little
oh now is it top turret yeah
uh i'm gonna hide behind the car
whoa um
oh lord oh no i tried
i tried
to tell my story oh my god there's too
many of them
andy no no no hate to see it
great great falls
hold the line like captain carry he said
oh
oh my gosh what a moment oh man
[Music]
used it to get out i'm going to hook
that as in howard
he's good is very good i got a back
cabin
back though
oh my gosh webcam
webcams webcams
the overwatch story yeah
the overwatch triforce
oh not anymore he's dead oh no
teleport on the back
oh i need directions well i was
deceased oh they were hello
silly season that hasn't quite kicked
off yet says fa
this i mean i feel like we're getting a
little bathroom hurting
uh no he's next to the car no
nice
[Music]
oh that same old lasts far too long
that sim alt is god remember when uh
back in the day when the teleporter used
to be right
or the shield oh [ __ ] the symptoms
essentially absorbed by zenyatta oh no
get that zen trying [ __ ]
i'm in the lava
thank you for killing that nice all
right any of the
zen to the left send to the left
everyone gang up on this end up front
all right sorry enough yeah let's just
focus the zenyatta
without him that little crumble
like a house of cards
yahtzee oh you're what you fart i went
too far i'm coming back i'm coming back
they'll have a lot of vaults now yeah
i've got mine
i don't know she's she's not as useful
as she used to be
no oh no no no where is that i have no
idea
oh my god everybody's dead i watched you
all die
almost everybody died oh my god
no i got full
i was seconds away from having my tracer
alt and i was going to throw it on the
point and then this zen just is
ridiculous yeah yes it
clips me in the face and he absorbed so
much damage
i mean this was a throw but like yeah i
think i think we said it was ten dollars
for every loss right it would be denoted
by someone in the chat yeah something
like that so please
we're up to seventy dollars yeah please
someone in the chat donate ten dollars
for that loss
uh oh uh oh no we have to split
i'm gonna joel i'm gonna give it to joel
give it a go
oh [ __ ] that was bad we got some cameras
there's a lot of damage i'm gonna read
some donations we've got a bunch in uh
fa hello mate 25 with hello
uh anonymous gave 50 dollars um
half a dozen don
donuts um us if i cut off the the latter
half of your name i'm sorry i recognize
that name yeah
well thank you for twenty five dollars
um gerardo was cool
with another five dollars and said andy
said my joke was terrible
and to donate again here we are
wow you know gerardo you don't have to
try to have this you don't have to have
a rebuttal for everything that's another
donation right there come on oh my god
got it got him got him wow
dan casey with a hundred oh damn
what a sweetheart keep keep up the great
work gamespot team thank you for raising
money for such a great cause glad to see
a rad crew playing overwatch
i need healing i need to plane lane
that's on me and you then
is it bad crew or rad crews rats
right yeah i mean even if it was even if
it was
bad i would have edited it uh matt
hawking with ten dollars
and he just says aim assist thank you
matt matt has been uh donating
every stream so thank you thank you and
us with twenty dollars
thank you 465 dollars away from 10 grand
let's go come on
we can do that we can do that we won't
win unless you get to 10 grand that's
probably that's a guarantee
[Music]
a little better about myself now they
got to that point way faster than we did
guys
oh did they have a teleporter
we were just uh we're hanging out
we were doing an important part oh the
double charge
uh we're doing an important part of uh
team teamwork which is just hanging out
uh focus the diva focus the diva again
we're doing call outs today we're
run gun runs right baby
truly loving to see it truly
oh brian right right ryan is so freaking
low
hello oh i missed him here i am uncle
moe thank you ma'am
dude so freaking low
all right they're pushing on the right
hand side
go diva
oh
um
james james you want to sync up buddy
uh sure
just just distract her for a little bit
okay okay
i'll i'll get all over the ass i got a
bunch
oh that ash got away from me oh there's
like one then
less than one even i really want it
sends out
running away like a cow where the hell
did she go get back here no how did i
miss her
we took it back home
great job doing good guys
he's got a gold hammer so you know he's
serious
a lot of comp hours dedication
nice nice you've been coming in either
coming in from the left
i'll let you go i don't know
okay we've got nash
we all do yep so my lashes are bigger
than others
he sold the year
there we go let's go big round win
too late for that mate big round win
just
give me lucy heels and we're good to go
that's all we need in business
feels good it's good oh wow i honestly
think that may be the first time i've
ever won that point
really ever in general yeah i think
you're about to say
i think that's the first time we've ever
won as a team and i was like
it's a process actually i'm gonna
swap
this point gives me nightmares i yeah i
don't care for it
yeah they come they have a doomfist they
have a dude
oh god yeah they gotta do fist picks me
off real quick
good lord
oh my god again not they're not fooling
around this time
hi cleveland public library i hope you
genuinely are the library i've seen your
name in
um chat a few times i hope you read the
other library
but it's okay if you're not but in my
head you are
mold diva bold bold and
coordinated
i had them all dead to rights down there
wait you actually are cleveland public
library oh that's amazing
the cleveland product library and
they've just said that overwatch is a
big game in their community
oh that's amazing i love this this is
incredible
this is the feel-good story of the apron
oh big red big
that tracer just walked off the edge of
the map
let's go james come on face it died on
the way bubba and this
diva hates life wouldn't you when you
play against
our team and i know that's right point
great point cleveland public library
uh has been hosting gaming and esports
events for years
so you do overwatch what else do you do
that's awesome
that's really damn cool visit the
cleveland public library
oh i tried to body block i'm sorry i'm
sorry
i'm gonna die i'm going to die
yeah i'm sorry i'm dead i'm i'm
literally rolling up my sleeves
business time yeah i've taken my show
off
okay it's okay we're feeling good okay
all right all right
it was worth it i chunked them off
oh alone zen okay
then oh yeah for a bad time
[Music]
all right nelly
all right i'm gonna wait should i wait
should we group yeah let's just regroup
hold on
yeah that's just regroup all right oh
man
all right joel joel's going joel's going
joel's got us all yeah i was seconds
from killing the ryan who was blocking
all the bobby shots
all right ready come on team come on
okay i'll go in
this round i just need one percentage we
just need uh joel to drop his alt
we are the one percent
we could do it here doing that doing my
halt
oh did they eat my all right i didn't
realize that was the thing is that
no he was in it but then he's still
loading yeah
we're good we're good we're good here we
go i'm coming i'm coming
not this no
we're good we're good we're good where's
that right
this is some absolute [ __ ]
maneuvering i'm freezing the hip so
you're gonna get him when he's down he's
right here they're gonna have to move at
some point
okay oh all right
[Applause]
yeah oh look at all those fires
that's a lot of fire it's happening my
goodness
that was what's happening going to the
top baby
the hell is this
glitch what is this some of the most
amazing plays of my life
oh you pressed the cuba on one time cool
cleveland public library does uh smash
that's officially supported by look at
that
[Music]
uh i don't know who to i'm gonna you
know and i vote i voted for james
i voted for luke james i always called
for hillary
i have never been closer to booking a
flight to la than when
i saw i believe it was your release
posting we are doing our first
fast and furious watch along or just
like walk through
i have never because i'm just
immediately booking a fight and saying i
need to be
there for this what's the progress where
are we at oh yeah
we are we are in the midst of fast
i have six i've seen the first one and
the third one i've seen the third one
probably
15 16 times right and i've seen the
first one a bunch but i had never
actually seen all the other ones so
we're going through right now
and uh and i can say right now it's
interesting because i know other people
are doing it too because i'm kind of
like pulling their feedback
and someone was like oh i really love
too fast too furious
for me objectively the worst objectives
objectively the worst yep wait which one
too fast too fast too furious no
james would you say that i would say
tokyo drift
do you think tokyo drift is worse than
too fast too furious yeah okay so oh no
the protagonist stuck in tokyo drift
yeah
so that's the problem blaine is like i
love i love
han right obviously everybody loves han
yeah but when the main character of your
movie
is that not great it kind of stinks but
i still think too fast is
less entertaining and just like it's not
even a good fun
bad for me it was just kind of just bad
yeah but there is a moment
in two when roman and brian go into that
nightclub and
roman goes it's an oasis in here
that's true controversial statement
controversial statement i can't stand
roman
i agree i agree i'm with you i'm with
you i think roman sucks i think
i think i think luda is is is much more
entertaining
like he's the same kind of like wild
card kind of character
what you'll like is later on as it keeps
going it becomes like the luda always
messing with roman
yeah i mean i saw the thing where he's
like oh we uh
you know we like don't whatever you do
don't fire the
like rocket launcher or whatever and
he's like okay and then he fires the
rocket launcher
right like so i'm already kind of at
that point in things
but yeah it's it's rough
but i am enjoying that having a great
time even behind us
furniture nice
all right okay okay right and
you know we've got we've got the payload
that heals yeah if anything we've got
three heels
and while behind behind
quick reminder to folks watching that
you can go to tinyurl.com2021 to donate
please donate
we're trying to get to 10k brothers
we're so close yeah
just 500-ish more dollars 400.
very nice very very nice we're going to
make people start quitting
this is going to get ridiculous yep
we're powered by charity yeah powered by
good vibes
this is this is all skill brought to you
by ablegamers
have a good time yeah let me give you
some juice
this is just this is disgusting right
here this is what you truly love to see
it feels so good though
the other night while i was playing uh
valor throw i kind of had this like
mission impossible very similar to fast
and furious everywhere
the second movie is not oh it's my least
favorite
it's bad yeah and then the later ones
get better for me
and i just really enjoy the later ones
well because they embrace what the
series becomes
yeah there's a huge quality difference i
feel like between them
i i kind of like you guys are saying
guilty pleasure love
for for mission impossible too it's like
a different universe
yeah but then you go into mission
impossible so dave and i
um a regular day
gamespot employee um are currently
living together and we did all fast and
furious
when i first came back and now uh we're
in the middle of doing all of mission
impossible
so we're just having conversation while
destroying this team like i know
it's unnecessary this is what is called
flow state
the absolute i've had
three whiskeys so that's
what's flowing through me i was tempted
to get a wine
that's tyrese's character in fast and
furious would say this is the whole
state
yeah we got one quilt
check can we get some money because we
make sure we have 50 dollars for a quit
please
donate money because we bullied someone
come on guys come on yeah
rewarding use them in the name of
charity oh my god i shot her in the back
oh we played against her last game on
busan
oh no we're him might be him
guys can be bad at games too
i am living proof a lot
oh my gosh this is ridiculous right here
this is
kind of gross i haven't even used my oh
yeah
are they where it counts oh my god oh my
lord
yep that's so true that's true stuck
around i don't have enough for all of
you but
oh oh oh yeah we did play shiny pants in
air roon because i can't reward him
and sam with three a's or two a's or
whatever
huge same holy cow
21 eliminations i think that's what i
had too it's just the kill streak
wow and they're gone
amazing uh we got
ten dollars from brandon hernandez thank
you it says bleed blue
andy that's difficult to say quickly
it's it's supposed to be burned blood i
don't know what the hell you're saying
well he wrote bleed blood brandon come
on
that deserves another ten dollars yeah i
think it's burn blue we all like come on
man
uh dorado is cool with another five
dollars all right
all right andy but these were the five
dollars i was gonna use to resub to you
in july
with 20 love the cause love the crew
time to go pro
i agree you bet oh i'm playing tank now
all right
i don't wanna i don't wanna please don't
this is bad
horizon
horizon andy i just wanna follow up on
on earlier you know
nothing's stopping you my friend well
tonight i'm gonna go see past nine
actually
oh damn other movies we could watch
other movies mission impossible
what what franchise has nine things we
can just watch this
star
uh no yeah i popped in six because i was
gonna kind of just skim through six
seven and eight
um my goddamn you just it's like i can't
skim through this i gotta watch this
whole
thing and just be part of the family you
could watch the mcu movies
oh god i cried conjuring
andy hey i saw it three the other day
mm-hmm yeah
i love the rings oh come down let's do
lord of the rings marathon
wow without me without me you're welcome
too but i mean
the embassy and whatever can you can you
get me back in the country
do you think that is a viable like
excuse yeah i
i hear that the embassy is opening up
appointments for people who just really
want to watch the order
my friends are doing a load of rings
screening can i go joel you destroyed
that song
yeah you got her uh arisa's got this oh
we're just we're just pushing in here
we're just push it in here i don't think
so
nice it's looking good it's looking good
no more shields no more shields
uh echo up top oh i'm down i need to
back out of it
somewhere's down is down i think the
echo is still knocking around somewhere
no i killed it okay cool we have based
on
it again this is the same squad no it's
not
can not be stopped guys cube enigma says
i assume this computer can't handle
video and overwatch
yes that is true so every now and then
this is it hitches for a second every
now and then this has got a 1080 ti in
it which should be fine to run overwatch
on his own but
it's also streaming and using discord
and
i mean i think also when you're playing
at a pace like this yeah yeah when
you're playing again
at this level who boot me who boot me
ball is here
i just want to go behind on ball
you're coming around behind this
does this sombra not know that she can
go invisible
she doesn't seem like her echo behind
where is she where oh she's right behind
me
um if you want to all get on point i can
help
a lot of you let's just get some pick so
let's get some pics
discord on
yeah echo finally figured out how to
hack are you kidding me
how is this lucio still dead
i'm laughing there's loads of tiny
characters moving
all over the place i can't get anyone a
real small team
oh yeah she got out of there sorry guys
oh come on
yeah dang it oh
oh there's that song where she's
unvisible she knows she vanished
maybe she's stream sniping i hear
echo i don't know people making money
for charity
shame
mercy is so low nice
what how is she still alive
oh you counted lucille discord
mercy discord huge lovely
oh god hamsa balls
behind the box
oh huge huge got mercy oh
oh my lord what saves
where is he going all discord
oh my goodness it's another dominant
performance from
all of us is this three in a row andy
there's three in a row let's go i do
one of y'all altered uh it was time
time's great oh oh beautiful
might have been a discord in there too
somewhere yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure
i'm gonna go to the restroom real quick
but let's just let's just keep this
rolling just keep this one
hold on yeah what time you need bud we
can go fire cover
while andy's uh emptying his bowels
let's just take an opportunity
to remind folks while we're doing this
hit him lucy
i thought you're going to take it when
you threw it to me um
so we are we are streaming uh we've been
streaming all week
in uh for i can't speak we are streaming
for ablegamers a incredible charity that
works
with various elements uh in order to
make gaming more accessible for people
with disabilities whether that is
helping to combat social isolation so
like
over the last year done about you guys
but the way that i've kept in touch with
most if not all of my friends has been
through playing games online
and we kind of take for granted that
there isn't really a barrier to entry
for us actually just being able to pick
up a pad and play like
some people with disabilities just can't
do that so ablegamers works
with engineers they uh to create
specialized hardware
they work to make games themselves more
accessible if there are accessibility
options within your game it's very
likely that ablegamers would have had
some hand in uh consulting on those
they do incredible work and their
overall mission is so that everyone can
game
uh which is super super admirable and so
we are raising money
to uh help fund that uh we are so close
to ten thousand dollars
so if you have any spare dollars to
fund first of all this this ragtag
crew of gamers uh please uh hit up the
link tinyurl.com
slash playful 2021.
do we win again do we play another game
right now possibly one wow that was
happening
yeah it's the pipes blaine i know that
you're
a little hesitant to play damage do you
still want me to queue for
healing just in case i'm doing flex
because
you know whatever the team needs i'm
just gonna let fate decide because
okay look look at us go guys you know
yeah i'm gonna hey i like that
i'm gonna put on some tank because i
would
feel just you know diva she calls to me
like a siren in the night here i can
uncheck tank
that way i you have more of a chance if
you want i'm good i know that like just
puts me on damage but
i we can always switch off i don't mind
you know i i maybe i should uncheck i'll
do
i'll do support and then maybe
damage i don't know where you guys need
me the most
i'll just do it all it's fine but this
is the way this team works
that's how we have so much success we're
always on the same page because when you
get
when you get to the post season it
doesn't matter how much talent you have
it matters the experience and we've been
there
we've seen what it takes to win these
really crucial matches when
the normal player will just break down
mentally they don't have the mental
fortitude and we definitely have been
there before so
we gotta just act like we've been there
you're right andy that's why there's a
lot of 55 year old players in the nba
it's because experience is the most
important thing exactly yeah
if if i had to identify one weakness and
this takes a lot of
you know this is a lot of honesty coming
out one plane we got it in our team
no no it's that we've never hit rock
bottom
you know we're so used to winning and
keeping that keeping those w's coming in
that like we've never truly hit rock
bottom so we don't know what that feels
like
but you know i think we just won't allow
it no
sure and also sometimes joel doesn't
click
except he hasn't clicked the redial
button wait what
oh man other than that
same page that was our wrong page
i gotta turn my ac back on there'll be
noise underneath me i apologize it is
toasty here you are in that ac
you had that big ultier in that
why someone oh oh god no not this map i
can't tell if that was for horizon luna
or for busan
all right
how about that okay here we go oh wait
andy did you get a new monitor
boxy is asking in chat i did yeah
asking how it is what'd you get i love
this thing i got a samsung
[Music]
is one of those big curvy ones hashtag
sponsors what's the thing
way up in the foreground in the bottom
left corner come on let's bring it
together
that's the monitor it's just too big
there it is oh man it's nice though i
yeah you like the way that looks yeah
it's really nice real nice
i can push it back but i like the
monitor being kind of closer to me you
know
yeah uh
last time i played overwatch it was with
joel
and he confessed to me that he's never
gotten the basketball in ever
i tried every time never happened
james that was my secret shame well i
mean
listen you put it out there you seem
very sad
all right
[Music]
i mean joel i literally had to look up a
youtube video on how to do it so
i'm i am that close
i got blowed up
that's okay that's okay all right all
right
okay we want to we want to let them
build their confidence a little bit just
so we can just
smack them down okay so is that what
that
here's the thing what is what is the
button to switch lucio's modes
on pc it should say wait it's [ __ ]
are you playing a mouse and keyboard i
shift i found it i found it i found out
yeah
okay okay we're good we're good i got
very confused there for a second
we're just constantly in speed yes i was
like why isn't it changing and i'm
pressing like second mouse click
the boop button i was also muted for a
long time where i'll shout and please
help me please help me please help me
and no one could handle it
oh junkrat's down oh no no no well that
matters
he's back oh
oh my god oh my god
there's a lot of shields on this team
and i don't really appreciate it
yeah i'm gonna like i never play junkrat
but i'm just gonna switch to junkrat
just because i feel like it'll help with
the shield
i don't know what i'm doing with this
dude science will reveal the truth
we'll see how it goes
wow they're busting my shields speaking
of i'm gonna try and go around their
back
get in their booty
i keep getting picked
i have a supercharged but i don't know
that we're ready to do it
blizzard's out there we got someone i
got junkrat
oh my god look there the webcams
just like held me back yeah we could use
i think we should go if it's possible a
windstone
um i've almost got my alt so i can swap
we are not going to make this basically
over there we go we gotta go
yeah we'll we'll go to the next round
it'll be fine we'll bounce back
i'm not pissed off we're doing great
this one i'm gonna i think reaper is
pretty important on this one
with how close everything is i hope they
don't go echo
should i go should i go hamster should i
go should i go dirty
do it yeah disgusting yeah go on
yeah just latch on and feel the g's oh
my god
if they can't have it nobody can
i knew i was that was the one for me i
knew it
careful you got two people you're going
to be dropping out of two people got a
junkrat who isolated us over here at the
back
we gotta be careful if we have hamster
and oh i'm gonna die
yeah we've got a uh lord
cody says but the team that battles from
rock bottom will beat all of you out of
the water
wow no almost you're asleep no
thanks girl
because there's a symmetra of course
don't forget she's annoying god the
shields in this game why are there so
many
yeah damage mitigation
i don't even know come back can you come
back is winston a good shower here
because he's just getting i'm just
getting melted
i think i'm gonna go back to ryan this
is just this is just ugly stuff
oh no
i don't think this is a good pick i want
to go
mercy
good lord there's three shields yeah
it's tough because we're diving real
hard on oh my god
oh my god oh my god just
trapping people and throwing grenades
out of thank you this teammate we're
we're all classed right here it's okay
it's okay
okay erisa's down oh would love a heel
i'm coming i'm coming i tried
[Music]
how did this freaking loose deal kill
mercy slaps
poisonous frog in it being you blaine
oh no god no there he goes
this is bad i'm leaving i'm getting out
of here oh no
oh
[Music]
i was stunned i was stunned out of it
and then i was killed oh my lord
too many shields it's not shield watch
it's not allowed to be allowed ban this
burn this [ __ ]
thank you cleveland public library
thank you i did see in the chat
somewhere you did say that you're
reopening soon and i hope that goes well
and i hope lots of people visit and i
hope that your
tournaments go well let us know what
you're doing them but thank you for
tuning in and watching
shout out to cleveland beams i just
gotta fight the bullet and go
symmetra like she's just so op i just
hate playing her i feel sorry
yeah she's gross oh you know where it's
thanks guys it's great teamwork right
there i got it for symmetra
oh why hey you didn't have to tell me
that
405 away everybody let's go
405 we're an hour in come on baby
how much would you pay for an overwatch
league ticket
uh probably 105
yeah here yeah whatever it is
it's a steal just to donate you know you
don't get to see the players in their
natural habitat like you are now
mm-hmm they know why they can't
uh blindly elvis says love seeing the
donation progress but we can't see the
score of the match
that is a good point yeah that's that's
because uh
this this layout makes it incredibly
difficult to show the top half of the
of the screen i can try
neither but it means that you just need
to trust that we're winning
every time yeah do you want symmetra or
do you
do you not want symmetra no not on this
map
yeah i'm fine going with uh any on
that map i just feel like everybody
always goes sim and
simmons i was just kind of avoided
oh there's probably donations uh oh no i
lost connection to the game server
oh wait that's a weird comment
it says who left that sorry we were
unable to log you in
why are you why are you playing a
pirated copy of overwatch
wow
someone someone tried to hack my
microsoft account literally yesterday so
oh wow who knows office 365 messages i
was getting those as well it's like
no i had no no i had um an authenticator
request
for somewhere in the united states and i
was like well
i'm not there it was in austin texas i i
i can explain uh
well i know i know like you know i have
trying to do your account
so it's understandable i can't make it
work i can't make the
overlay move it covers up everyone's
face
oh okay um things are getting dicey on
the front line
there's a uh yeah there's a reaper up
top
yeah there he is oh oh no i'm going to
find the little heel
health pack okay there's an echo there
too oh my god these
these are aggressive oh okay he's down
oh help me
okay
good luck ah
that's okay i didn't want that point to
begin with that point strokes
defense honestly let's keep this match
going 15 seconds is like a good amount
of time to hold yeah
lord that's like don't say hi to me
roadhog
look i'm not conversing with you okay
okay oh god okay what are you doing
and that was a mistake so i will be
going back because
i just didn't work out for you
roadhog's up
yeah he top is they're just they're just
muscling their way in here
oh my god okay hogs down hawks
ah
oh my gosh
[ __ ] freak sorry no bad words
cleveland public library was here come
on
stop embarrassing us in front of the
cleveland public library
there are children watching
oh you coward
stop whatever oh this ryan help with
this ryan oh put up pretty bad
[Music]
i overshoot that no he just saved it
it's okay it's okay it's okay seven and
a half minutes to push
the edge no way perfect
okay yeah i will i will check that out
thank you cleveland public library
oh no i walked into that fire strike
that was such a bad mistake
oh come on how is that allowed
sending all this stuff look at the
distance on this ridiculous
roadhog's behind you guys uh ryan
and reaper in here ryan's low mine's low
i've got my alt
echo is extremely low good lord
that this is this is more in line with
what a usual overwatch
no the other teams
we needed we needed to be humbled a
little bit i think that's all this is
and then
he's happy slapping that's what he's
doing oh yeah so great
oh come on why do i even throw down this
keep me alive
i'm very alone and then me
yeah grip is like one of my favorite
things that my dad says
get a life and get a great oh no
bobby oh no blood arms in chat how are
the games going
uh they steamrolled
we run on donations and i think that's
what we're missing right now
we need donations yeah yeah yeah that's
our that's our
fuel yeah we did get a couple
um from yannick
um boyle la and then tiltify is
hopefully cut off the last half of your
name i'm so sorry about 15
from yannick dear andy i totally believe
you can beat greg tomorrow
oh good luck andy thank you thank you
i'm not looking forward to this honestly
uh
dollars and five cents from jimmy dean
d james dean jimmy dean
i'm hungry that's big and then like
some of us went sausage and some of us
went james dean
wait who's sausage
sausage also i want to know who who knew
james dean so well that they called him
jimmy
someone who's me it was me it was me
it was me it was me okay
uh and then flying elvis oh is it defend
down
flying elvis 27 with ten dollars
love seeing so many of my faves on one
stream for a good cause click those
heads and rip into shreds nitro rifle
exactly we're going to do it right here
i'm feeling better and better about it
i'm changing my skin i think that was
the problem with it
that's what it was that's a good idea
this is unfortunate i'm not good with
any of these characters
oh what are you i'll go soldier or
soldier
i'm terrible i don't soldiers knew
recoil
no they've lessened that at least last
time i i tried him
all right let's see how we get on i
think you play valor and you know what a
recoil is yeah
but like there's a million shields in
this game like i i can deal with it when
it's like a couple of taps in the right
area and they're gone
yeah well keep in mind that he's helix
rockets are every five seconds
yeah yeah bam those bad boys true yeah
your soldiers wearing eyeliner that's
pretty cool
oh yeah did you i
don't ask me how my brain works that i
jumped to this but did you see that
video of avril lavigne
joining tick-tock
yeah so she's joined tick tock and she
did a little
mine along to her oh there's a genji
behind
uh to her fantastic hit skateboard and
then
cut to tony holt he was escaping
they're all coming up the stairs contest
but also avril lavigne has not aged in
the last 20 years
which makes me think that she actually
was replaced oh
no we're trading blows oh lordy this
team is crazy
we got stomped up they they plowed right
through it yet
oh thank you beautiful revival i managed
to save you but at what cost
that's a waste of life i went right back
to being dead
i hit
that sounds like a shower thought like
when you go to bed are you just hitting
the snooze button online
thank you it's okay i want this game to
last longer everybody all right
i'm making it i am not long for this
world oh my god
i'm not checking my corners and stuff
it's a very aggro oh
no oh
don't
a minute hold on we're just playing
playing blind and blind blaming god
i'm waiting yeah i just wanted to go
if they've gotten the memo that we're
raising money for charity i've never
played widow
properly so let's see how this goes they
said they're playing widow
for charity i'm doing playing widow for
cherry it's the opposite of charity
um evil
why i'm holding the controller up like
this and uh this is because
i'm in that was a mistake my pro gamer
stance time i'm not going to raise you
because you're playing with
them yeah i shouldn't have even come up
here they've cornered us off by the way
from the point they have cornered us
okay we're doing this what is even
happening why am i
doing jesus we're trapped in the old
spawn as they move the point past
us
you're trapped in here with me and you
got one
one time yeah you got two
stop the momentum let's do it
oh nope
all right all right all right so there
it is solid switch ups there it is
from real cheese ball i like it
like am i proud of it no will i take it
yes
listen we can play the shield game we
can do that we sure can
let's do it and put a turret down
i think uh genji's gonna have old um
how do i heal myself oh like this
good lord that reinhardt's mean
it's okay
get out of here
mercy is hurt burning yeah
oh i tried to get her okay okay
oh my god what i just saw andy get
deleted off the screen
back up oh that's getting
oh my god it's a very aggro team
i don't appreciate it oh
no i just tried launching myself up oh
my god she pops us in fiber bullying
bullying
that was ugly
stop being sweat
tell them damn
genji was ridiculous angie
it was so unfortunate because i i had
headshot on lucy
and he was super low went for another
headshot and he perfectly
deflected it on my head unbelievable
right back in my face
all right dang it
it's okay it's okay okay i'm gonna go to
i'm going i'm going to standing desk
mode
oh
you're uplifting your life i'm going
standing desk mode too
i'm going standing guest mode joel's
penis
guess won't activate
with standing desk mode but remain
[Laughter]
seated
movie that stars jared butler
oh like that yeah a secret service kind
of thing
he just keeps staying through every
administration i'm an american scientist
what was that maybe it was like yeah i'm
trying to think of it lucy i can't deal
storm oh
no no no
uh what's the movie where he's like it's
the one where the right hundred conveyed
angel has fallen olympus is full red
gone
and angel has spawned yeah both of them
i was thinking of the one where he gets
um falsely accused
of uh killing his wife and then he says
i am a
yeah like a normal citizen
or yeah
[Music]
or something yeah i need to know
law-abiding citizens
like someone just wrote it into the
script and they're like yeah we'll
change it later
that'll work wasn't he in a movie about
being a gamer
he was yeah gamer
it was originally called citizen game
which is the website that me and danny
that's the website that me and danny
o'dwyer put together before we went to
gamespot
and then you were like nummy yeah
she ate my freaking dynamite how dare
her
dino maize behind your head
time back up it was james wait i
was so confused i see you're sorry i'm
just pushing
let's push it on the healer yeah yeah
let's go
charge we're good run to the point
thank you get that diva kenji on the
point uh
i need help on the phone come in
hey finally oh that was fine
that's not a wall oh my god
no one saw that everything's fine no no
all right 15 seconds just like we like
yeah oh wait james is going in center oh
they are all burning oh my god
okay shields return
that goes above you guys
oh no run lane let's stay out of there
oh no let's get out of there
oh ryan
oh my god oh god i'm on the way
do echo sucks take her out of the game
oh my god they're all here it's going to
be lucy
[Music]
back back
reinhardt could just thrust backwards
they're away
yeah they pushed out way too far oh
again chubby slime what a great name
we could just run back to the point i
think we should
yeah we're getting picked we're getting
picks
now we push diva back here she's about
to be demect
echo i just get on the point just get on
the point
yeah let's go that's good teamwork right
there
make your mother proud
oh no oh what an ult
you're all one gracias
he
yes
oh no [ __ ] inbound
she's weak
[Music]
i was in the middle of it oh
no
oh wow he's coming back in
oh symmetra's on me how are they
still how ball bombs ng
mission symmetra placement
is ash because i have alt
bob did it standing desk is
i'm almost there they were like who's
gonna shift
right here
yeah let's go looks like we're going up
middle
at least to pull their focus i i killed
their tp we're gonna turn around in a
second
the toilet paper all right i got my i
got my
oh we got two there we go
oh no uh
i'm stunned i'm sorry i just missed you
that's okay i got
bopped in the face
desk that's what it was
trying to convince the players to donate
to our charity
i love that i love it shout out
cleveland library sound cream
mvp of this uh whole stream
oh look at that
i'm giving it to you man yeah i don't
know that was good
you know control said the most
concentrated group of players i've ever
seen
yes it's almost not entertaining lucy
that's like uh so we got twenty dollars
from
cassie c he says love the calls love the
game love the people
just ordered some papa john's hell yeah
whoa
oh extra garlic sauce
i i i down i donated
and it hasn't gone through yet i don't
know what the heck is going on i think
if i say i downloaded papa john's
yeah you wouldn't download a papa jones
i don't know what the heck is going on
mine didn't mind did that yesterday it
just stayed on processing forever
so maybe this will be a double donut
we'll see hell yeah all right either way
lucy just paid me back right
you got it
i'm so tired of defending i want to
attack yeah they only put the best
players on defense
yeah right yep good call
much longer did you know that you can't
use venmo unless you're both physically
in
the united states actually i venmo
someone in the united states
what yeah you told me that it wouldn't
it wouldn't let me do it unless i was
physically counted
i did it yesterday i then mowed my
roommate
um
you could also try doing it online on a
web browser but using a vpn to act like
you're in the states
oh is this a is this a nord vpn this
one's uh
this ep episode of the stream is
sponsored by nordvpn
wow shout out no doubt
wherever
i might go on the cleveland library's
website and see if they've got like a
t-shirt that they sell
i'd buy a cleveland library website yeah
future
i want cleveland library to have like
esports shirts yeah
i want a cleveland library tattoo wait
so
so we have like the london spitfire san
francisco
yeah what would our cleveland library
name be the cleveland library
cleveland library bookworms yes
[ __ ] there it is but they'd be like
really angry worms yeah
oh yeah furious like the worms from
worms yeah
i don't know i think team 17 will be all
right yeah
we we'd obviously need to have a pro
worms team uh to get them
oh yeah if anyone has something
our fans can wear shirts that say i've
got the worms
oh yeah that's cool i'm smart i've got
the worms
i'm just being pushed back by this
reaper
oh bad oh there he is
this reaper just did not care remember
folks if you're watching we're almost at
10k
we'd love to get there we've got like
half an hour left help us
send send send a link to your rich
friend or your well-off friend
and just be like yo can you send a
d-line yeah just tweet out elon musk and
say listen you loser
do something good for once in your
shitty life you know
a friend in the top tax bracket yeah
just send them there you know a pure
teal yeah
if you know jeff bezos
before he takes off yeah say jeff real
quick
real quick before you go on we lock the
door behind you can you just donate to
this
i haven't been able to get the jeffrey
bazer song
from boba and was inside out of my head
like the last week
i can't do much because oh he's off
oh
oh yeah here we go that was dangerous
but
paid off it was worth it though i'll
never let you down
i'll never let go no
hell i let you down you
you put in the work though i appreciate
the ethic yeah
yeah get out of here
had enough time to come back waste my
old and go back to sleep
oh my god how did you get that one
you got you got the spirit
of whatever howards
standards
yeah he really won't no they reach the
payload no
i'm out of goo but it's okay oh jeez i
need help
oh my god okay summer and sunrise up
no thank you oh that was bad that was
dumb whatever i just did
no you didn't don't never do that again
stabilized finally that's amazing
relax
all right all right let's regroup
why did i do that i don't know oh i
cannot help over there oh
what oh come on
yeah alive
[Music]
oh someone help me with this with this
situation i've got andy i've got andy
all right come on let's go bully that
ryan
uh he's gone he's going on he's long
gone howard
i thought you said he pees down and i
was like
is that some new lingo
he's he's dead
yeah true gamers don't alt
we gotta break this ryan shield he's
just yeah he's low he's low
he's he run away
ow where's the hash
come on come on
[Music]
the point i'm just going to push it back
i do have my out
someone behind reaper behind your hand
break him oh he's running away
he's gonna come in behind you guys again
yeah uh i'm trying to seriously come
here
very nice
oh god great pin great pin up top
ash coming in behind oh no where is that
rope it's in where is it oh she's out in
front of you joel next to the car
oh wow how did he jump on there i i
pooped him
that's all right he's dead he's down
away
kind of a waste of my old i'm sorry oh
that's right go damage lucio
[Music]
[Music]
oh the rest thank you uh uh reaper just
teleported up top all right i i've got
an eye up top
hello there it is there it is very nice
thank you
oh it's the it's the cleveland library
bookworms
we've got worms guys come on
oh got her joel in chat uh
got him all right nice i got picked off
by memory foam that's why i was
complaining
come on dude all right back up back
up black up oh [ __ ] me no he's down he's
out
no oh my god now they they
behind reaper coming up there's a reaper
there
and he about 10 oh behind hog fine
bob's holding up for him
uh ryan is far left yeah i think he's
slightly he's coming through behind
nice nice
they're so freaking low back there oh my
goodness
nice oh nice this is oh lovely oh yeah
lucio get the lucio reefer behind
man great great call-outs great defense
holy crap
shields
no bob's taken care of are you kidding
me run
[ __ ]
oh no the mercy just destroyed me
okay okay both heels
okay rhymes down oh [ __ ] yes
no we're somebody's on point giving you
all
power
that alt was amazing luke that was like
the game changer
there it is wow there it is the game is
that's stopped the momentum
look at this oh you're a keyboard mouse
middle right you're not
controller anymore i was about to say no
i'm controlling still oh wow
as you can tell from what i did at the
end though the gamepad grim reaper
amazing one kills dude
that's a lot of kills
wow that was a fantastic game after
getting rolled so fast
yeah amazing yeah absolutely amazing
got back into it 240 dollars away
everybody we're so freaked out
so close um we got some donations
50 from andres cortez oh
she says the games sounds like a
handsome guy
but he's great dps uh elise williams
thank you i miss you uh twenty dollars
from anonymous
thank you so much uh twenty dollar
dollars from jimmy dean
james or sausage james dean yeah sausage
guy
james dean the sausage guy the aproman
the sausage king
um and uh 25 from anonymous thank you so
much
so close so close look what
i can't do mass 240 dollars 240 dollars
we can make it just over 20 minutes oh
attack once
i know one day we'll attack one day
oh wait james williams a hundred dollars
what are you doing in there what's going
on
oh thank you amazing you're so close
104 dollars away
all right ready to move and we're
defending which is our favorite we've
already had our best game so like
anything
everything else is just we're playing
with house money
oh man uh the series black 13 james and
blaine look like wrestlers waiting for
their music to hit
uh to make a run in and i love the
intensity that's the
that's the aesthetic yeah
that's what we're going for
bust that wall bring
down that wall don't get hooked by hog
he's going to go for one of those cheeky
hooks
a little cheeky i
oh i have had a nando since i've been
back i haven't kind of skinned
cheeky nandos
yeah it might be back up
oh no oh i am very alone
yeah richard wilcox time is the time is
the voice in the void
that's me baby he's also the game player
watching
yeah the pro the pro gameplay
they are bullying you right now
no i don't know you should have done
that you shouldn't i'm sorry
it wasn't worth it ah come on
can't be pinning on tiana
yeah this genji is i'm gonna
when you get tired of um busting ass and
diamond
you want to go into quick play and bully
some people yeah
that's what i've learned as a diamond
player
i thought i saw you in in the fellow
diamond ranks
oh no i barely played tom
yeah he's hacked get his ass got him
here we go
what happened to my dog
your microphone car that sounded like
you fell off a cliff
i'm not ready yeah my my internet's
having a time
it's like what's going on oh no lordy
lord
wow my this team is fantastic
yeah we want to get out of here quick
we'll we can play another game
oh my god they are
been playing they are bullying you
i feel like i i give my attention to
someone else for like two seconds
there's three of them on me
oh no go away what in the world i mean
absolutely sweaty
i mean it's like just have some fun guys
oh go away i don't know why i went
really british there
i'm playing to kick ass movie kicks
would you definitely play this earlier i
think
oh no i'm trading with this rind
oh he won yeah he sure did
where is everybody you're just hanging
out really everybody
i'm playing to impress a girl in my
class
that's fine i get that i get that
what's ablegamers oh leave me alone
oh
bookworms we made it to ten thousand do
we
hey
wow ten thousand two hundred and five
wow who gave him
who's that uh so anonymous
uh with 240 dollars wow
did we do it we did it
uh and then joelle reuben oh
oh that could be anyone who could that
be
thank you thank you joelle uh and soon
in 92 and five dollars thank you
legends we made it our goal do we want
to do
it's tax deductible it is everybody's a
winner
tilta fi logs in with your amazon pay so
you can use your bezos
books one more one more one more
yeah one more sure let's do one you know
what look how nice that team was they're
like yeah good on you all
good luck we already hit it so
piss off suckers
that is nice i missed that what'd they
say looks like a good charity that's
cool that's great
oh and then uh someone said i'm just
playing for the funny sword man
oh we were playing against that zen that
was really good
oh yeah they were anna that time oh
really
yeah i didn't recognize that
see i don't think about them you know
like i don't let them live run free in
my head you know
yeah change the requirements
for you know the unlocks in these events
it used to be like win nine things but
now i think it's 12.
it's a lot the wins count for triple now
yeah this is well isn't it if you play a
game you get one if you win you get two
or something like that oh that's a bad
balance
um cleveland live we are attacking
us this is like the perfect map to end
this
if if we win i think yes
we will pam's got some boobs going i
sure hope so
go team boops
cleveland library said they followed me
or at least someone from their team did
i don't think they have the info
in their bio so i don't know
just tell us if you can buy cleveland
library t-shirts that's all we want to
know
we playing the same team uh we're
playing yeah we're playing a decent
amount of the same players
and we're gonna show them what we're
really made of bingo
cakes yeah their banners look different
but not the but not the gender the zen's
gone
okay that's good
bingo was the zen from before bingo
bango
ah [ __ ] no no no no no no no
god damn it you knew it was going to
happen
i survived one boob only to get get
knocked by another
no leave me alone i'm just a little frog
boy
oh no can i pass on this stream y'all
yeah absolutely not that i would
we're just dead you can you're allowed
we made it to our goal so you can do
pretty much anything now
all right here we go
what what what get out of here uh
oh my god go away you're being so rude
please god
[Music]
oh no
oh music yeah the genji's still good
though it doesn't really matter who the
genji is
he's still a good player he's spicing
people up
he's solo altered on me oh you cow
you what holy cow
hello again do you see that in the chat
yeah
hello again
oh no um i have alt
so i'm gonna do a little oh well i'm not
now
i'm not even sure entirely what to do
here yeah yeah i
i i'm i'm a little closer oh there it is
i don't think that'll kill them though
yeah that'll just give them a little oh
that's a pick for genji
got him
oopsie cakes go away no one likes you
oh i'm sure you're very loved
um
okay well i mean i can't i can't get
anywhere near there thank goodness
oh god the telltale beep as well we
didn't even
get anywhere near them that was so hard
good round good round that was good
round the round
you cow you cow
remember the charity of cherry guys
oh what did you say if we lose they
don't get the money
[Laughter]
that's weird all right
with old faithful
man i just don't know i i was just so
useless that match i only saw the point
like three times
goals just get someone pushed off the
map that's all i want from this round we
just want some good
boobs some good old-fashioned home
cooked boots oh i hear
symmetra you sure do god damn it
why why can't we just play a nice
wholesome game of overall
oh help he did i think i'll bring
symmetra into this
how how bling swing joel
why do you stay in the corner you're
just taking damage
swing on that i'll die immediately i was
healing you you're gonna die
you're gonna die slower
oh my god wanna know what happened there
yeah i do
oh help me go away
you know what i'm gonna go sim let's
play dirty let's
beat them at their own game
oh
ah ah let me out of there
all right you ready
how do you play this dude oh no this is
so bad oh my god oh she's so low we
might have time for another game just
get this one out of the way
well i'm just hiding behind the point
somber sam just ran in i got it
the mood has changed scared
i'm scared guys
oh my lord i cannot catch a break here
yeah we're saying boops as in boops not
boots
boops on the ground oops
guys chris almighty um
no go away good numbers
we got numbers i'm coming in
oh nice
we did it guys we did it oh my god we
got
we've got some we're in there
she pissed me off so much i just wanted
to kill her come on man
man it seems really good
oh daily season
okay oh
i got i got a boop guys
i i got a move you got a little boopy
boo
oh where is she all right shots you got
to poop son
oh no oh wait andy oh no andy
oh dutch is cheering for us guys my dog
is cheering for us
oh that's a lot of heal i need a lot of
healing you guys are really hurt
okay yeah baby oh
there's a
you're good you're good you're good
you're good you're good holy cow
wow wow
absolutely like this is the bookworms
biggest enemy the cows
oh no oh my god
huge we did it
oh my god to just not get steamrolled
that is the symmetra effect
it sucks
don't do it joel oh my god
this time it was andy wait
did that listen for jeff bezos
yeah because i said that if we lose we
send all the money to bezos
that's fair
in the chat in front of you says we did
it we achieved cherry
[Laughter]
okay old even in charge out there
love it you got it go get him
yeah he will i'm gonna give him a little
you bet and it will all be orbeez
ow oh there's a turtle
yeah there's a turret up top okay okay
i got that i got you got it oh oh no
oh man i was so freaking close thanks
for the heels up dang it i almost got
him
okay they've got azaria anime
and i'm stuck in the middle of this [ __ ]
sandwich
good lord get back here
where's the turret
oh lava ground lava ground yeah oh i was
trying i thought i had my bubble i did
not
no no
oh no oh man all right all right all
right all right all right
all right it's it's it's uh
i i i'm gonna alt
and then i think i'm gonna switch off to
ash where the hell
this is the basically the first time i'm
playing zenyatta
mixing
i got the mercy
all right that's okay it's okay it's
okay i got a wall there's a tub in the
back
group up group group up group up
[Music]
god damn it
wow i got i got hosed
i'm stalling i'm stalling i'm coming
i'm not gonna make it rockets
they put fire stone down
lava god why can't i remember the name
dang it oh that was close
that was hard zealous says i just love
capitalism
i respect that i respect that hey
let's go
oh this wasn't me this was 100 not me
you're killing the turrets
that was that was your old lucy thank
you it was a team
it was a team alt
you're not telling them tam no they
don't need to prime subtops
oh we tried that was fantastic we tried
that was that was good
all right great match let's
i'm going to open my loot boxes and then
we're going to end this stream
oh we're doing a little unbelievable
unboxing what we got we got purple
all garbage we got another one another
one here we go
anything good all
garbage wow come on
one more for jeff kaplan
oh you're all garbage
you truly hate to see it yeah yeah
uh i just read out one more donation
that we got in uh from craig gilmore
um i supposed to say a friend of the
show oh a friend of ours in real life uh
who gave 30 and said super fun blast off
thank you so much mate
thank you so much to everyone who
donated and watched along
uh we hit our 10k goals
[Music]
yeah and thank you guys for joining and
donating
and just like being read the game to
play overwatch
the best overwatch crew you could ask
for
that's true thank you so much thanks for
inviting me
of course we'll play some more overwatch
again soon
yes please for sure we know it can work
now
we got it down we got it down no we're
playing on the american services yeah
all right folks yeah so we're back again
tomorrow morning 10 a.m pt
with our friends the giant bomb we're
going to be playing what's it called
we're playing jackpots
and there's another game that they
mentioned the tricky towers something
like that
or something like that which is going to
be a lot of fun guitars are great
uh that'll be our final charity stream
for this week um
our final charity stream actually for
this thing but we have a very cool
announcement to make at the end of the
stream too that you don't want to miss
um can you all tell me after the issue
oh yeah we can tell you we can tell you
but it's a big one you'll want to be
there it's cool
yeah so make sure you tune in
all right say goodbye everyone
bye bye everyone
oh i'm in charge i need to stop
streaming yeah